Game of Thrones season 6 episode 1 just
came out and some pretty crazy stuff
happens so let's get into it
we begin at the wall with John dead in
the snow Davos and ghost and some loyal
Knights Watchmen are in conflict with al
azhar Thorne who seems to be taking over
the watch after John's death Eid goes to
get the wildlings who probably won't be
too happy when they hear what happened
to Jon
Melisandre comes and says Shifa saw Jon
fighting a Winterfell and well so of way
that's probably him there in the trailer
there's heaps of evidence in the books
and the show that Jon will be back he
always comes back the only questions are
how and when and what he'll be like when
he rises but in the meantime conflict is
brewing with watchman and wildlings and
Davos in Winterfell Ramsay is also
mourning his dead in his own special way
heated at hand Ramsay's dad Roose
reminds him that Sansa is the Bolton's
best hope of controlling the north and
also that if Walder has a son that son
would inherit Winterfell ahead of the
bastard Ramsay so some people think that
Ramsay might end up killing Walder and
Roose this season meanwhile Theon and
Sansa are hunted by Bolton's Theon
bravely risks his life to try to protect
her which could hint at the beginning of
a redemption for him but the Bolton's
are closing in then Brienne and pod
appear to save the day and carve up the
Bolton's Sansa finally accepts Brienne
service and protection which is a
beautiful moment for Brienne mirroring
her pledges to Renly and Catelyn
hopefully she'll have better luck
keeping Sansa alive in King's Landing
Cersei is still reeling from a walk of
shame and she's crushed even further
when she finds out her daughter Marcella
is dead she talks about the prophecy of
Maggy the Frog who said that Circe's
kids would die it's interesting that the
show hasn't mentioned the other part of
Maggie's prophecy that Cersei will be
killed by her Vallon choir or little
brother which she thinks means Tyrion
but some readers think means Jaime
in any case Jaime says [ __ ] prophecy
[ __ ] everyone else we will take
everything back which will probably put
him at odds with the faith here we see
the high Sparrow and septa unella
playing good cop bad cop with Margaery
Tyrell who is still imprisoned along
with her brother Loras Cersei is not
exactly the biggest fan of the Tyrells
so it'll be interesting to see how much
the lasses and the Tyrells join forces
to face the faith down in Dorne olaria
and Ty in suddenly kill
Dornan and REO and Obara Nymeria kill
trystane in King's Landing and this is
pretty crazy because the motivation of
the sand snakes is that they want to
start a war against the Lannisters
because the Lannisters or rather the
mountain killed their father Oberyn and
earlier there aren't Elia Doran tries to
prevent war and that seems to be why
ilaria kills him but isn't it kind of
crazy to kill oberyn's family so that
you can avenge Oberyn further ilaria and
the sand snakes are all bastards with no
rightful claim over dawn will they even
be able to take control many book
readers don't like this change but maybe
the shows just cutting to the chase
getting to the point which is probably
that dawn will war against the
Lannisters and probably end up
supporting the Targaryen z-- that'll be
Daenerys in the show but maybe Aegon in
the books also it's cool to see Obara
Nymeria in King's Landing might be
they'll get in on the conflict maybe
they'll kill Tommen as NIM threatens in
the books it might also make sense for
them to go after Robert strong the
reanimated Mountain goes after all he's
the guy who killed Oberyn and Elia in
Mereen Varys and Tyrion rocks and sweet
caves talk about the rising political
tension and the threat of the sons of
the harpy and all this doom and gloom
looks to put Tyrion in a good mood he's
really starting to shake off his earlier
depression he's getting back into the
game so it'll be great to watch what he
and Varys can accomplish together they
pass a red priest preaching about
Daenerys being a Zora High which is cool
and mine foreshadow the arrival of the
priestess kinvaras sometime later it's
also interesting that the priest wears
the same hexagonal pattern we see on
Melisandre and Quaithe maybe meaning
this guy's from a shy finally we say
Danny's fleet burning in slavers Bay and
Tyrion's or lake looks like we won't be
sailing to Westeros but wouldn't it be
convenient if we knew some friendly
Vikings who could bring Danny some ships
meanwhile Jorah and Daario search for
Dany in the Dothraki sea they have a bit
of banter to stoke their rivalry we see
that jurors greyscale is getting pretty
gnarly and Danny's on the road to Vaes
Dothrak
the Dothraki City Dany suffers the whips
and harassment of her captors and keeps
our cards close to her chest only
revealing that she can speak to raqi
which is brought before Karl Morrow for
a moment things look like they might
turn around but then Danny finds out
that she's expected to join the -
Colleen the widows of dead calls who
live out their days in Vaes Dothrak
which is probably not what Danny has in
mind but in the books
tells Danny that to go forward she must
go back so this returned to the Dothraki
could be crucial in Danny's Ark moving
forwards she won't want to hang around
the Dothraki forever though so wouldn't
it be convenient if we knew a friendly
dragon who could fly into spirit her
away in Braavos iya is still blind and
is begging on the streets you can
briefly hear someone saying that
Kingsguard which is a reference to AI is
murder of Meryn Trant last season which
is cool but anyway the wave turns up and
proceeds to beat the absolute [ __ ] out
of IO which is meant to train her to use
all those senses though in real life
that kind of beating would give you a
fractured skull before daredevil vision
but regardless this suffering will
probably make is stronger even so there
may come a day when I has had enough of
the wave [ __ ] so he may soon see real
conflict between the two one little
thing in the books is that IU gets
around being blind by walking into a
cache entering into its consciousness
and seeing through its eyes like bran
does with summer hopefully they'll
include that in the show and then back
at the wall Melisandre reveals her true
form as a very very old woman which
actually makes a lot of sense
it's hinted in the show and the books
that Mel is older than she seems that
she's hiding her true appearance with a
kind of magic called a glamour the
glamour seems to work using this Ruby at
her net though she has been seen without
it before without looking old so maybe
that's a continuty error maybe the magic
works some other way but the real point
here is that Melisandre is nakedness
shows where she's at as a character
right now remember when we first met her
when she seemed so powerful and
beautiful and certain but all her hopes
and beliefs were founded on Stannis
Baratheon being a Zora hi the chosen one
of the Lord of Light and now that he's
dead she's lost everything her nakedness
is a moment of honesty and vulnerability
and humanity from someone who's now in
deep doubt over who she is and what she
believes it'll be amazing to see how she
comes out of this and what it might mean
for Jon Snow
so that is episode 1 of season 6 of Game
of Thrones we got a lot of characters
brought low beaten down disempowered
disillusioned
dead but there's a strong sense of
rising for revenge with Sansa and Dorne
and the Lannisters we've got a lot of
women kicking ass we've got religions
playing a part we've got magic and
politics and everywhere tension is
rising the stage is set and for the most
part no one knows what's coming next
thanks for watching if you'd like to see
a breakdown like this for every episode
of season 6 please let us know by liking
sharing subscribing and commenting what
you want to say next you might like to
check out our videos on therosis of mere
a red priest like male who also has a
crisis of faith and on John's
resurrection and on IU's character arc
thanks to all supporters on patreon
including Christopher Bryn's evan
windsor corner blank Ian your pal Fey
Harrison Jessica O'Keefe John crane
wells beat Richard Thomas Carlsen : van
Austin Jennifer Grasso and Keck 7 go
thanks again see you next time